there are nine very clear signs that
will tell you if you're in ketosis or
not now being in ketosis is very very
important not just to lose weight but to
get rid of a lot of health problems
diseases inflammatory conditions that
someone has and the problem with testing
yourself for ketones to see if you're in
ketosis or not is when you're doing a
urine test for example or a breath
analyzer test they're not very accurate
well maybe at first they might be a good
thing but as soon as you start to burn
ketones more efficiently those extra
wasted ketones are not going to show up
in your urine they're not going to show
up in your breath but those values could
be zero so those tests are are not very
accurate now blood test is pretty
accurate but you know it's expensive you
have to stick yourself there's a little
pain involved but I'm going to show you
nine different signs or Clues to tell
you if you're in ketosis or not now
number one relates a bit more to
transitioning into ketosis usually it
takes about two to three days depending
on how low your carbs are and there's
usually three uh symptoms that a lot of
people have if they don't do either the
B vitamin supplements or electrolytes
and sea salt because all three of these
transitional signs or symptoms can be
related to something missing in the diet
because when you do keto you need more B
vitamins and a lot of times you need
more electrolytes and that would be
number one keto flu
number two keto fatigue and number three
keto rash now if you're doing the
healthy version of the ketogenic diet
and you're really making sure that your
foods are nutrient dense and higher
quality the chances of you getting these
symptoms are much less versus someone
doing the dirty version of Keto which is
basically you're just doing low carb and
you're not paying attention to the
quality of foods and another side note
on that if you get diarrhea for example
um that usually is related to consuming
a lot more vegetables because I
recommend that you do include a good
amount of greens or Salad on this
program to get certain minerals and
certain vitamins but some people are
just not used to consuming like seven
cups or ten cups of salad per day and so
because they don't have the microbes to
break all that fiber down they might get
diarrhea on the flip side people that
have keto breath that's usually related
because they're not consuming enough
greens to kind of counter some of the
the ketones that you're breathing out
but let's go to number two this is a big
one this is called weight loss okay
you're going to lose weight initially
you may lose a lot of weight like 7 to
14 pounds in the first one to two weeks
now why do you lose so much weight
initially because simply the first part
of this weight loss is going to be water
weight loss when your body has been
consuming a lot of carbs with that
stored glucose you also store a lot of
water so for every gram of glucose that
you store your body stores 3 grams of
water so it's like three times as much
water so people that do a high carb diet
are literally they're just filled with
water when you start getting them off
carbs they dump and get rid of a lot of
water weight so the first week or even
week and a half they might lose a ton of
weight and then it comes down to like
one to two pounds loss and they're
usually depressed at that time because
they think wow it's not working anymore
so maybe I should go into another diet
when in fact it was working they just
didn't realize it was water weight you
have to realize that the most fat you
could possibly burn per week is about
two pounds and that's with a healthy
body now that's not including a lot of
fasting that's just going on this Keto
Plan because if you start adding more
fasting and like you're fasting for some
days and then the weight loss goes up to
three four five or even a little bit
more weight of actual fat loss per week
but when you start losing weight
especially after the second week when
all the water is gone then you can kind
of know that you're burning fat and the
way it's coming off all right number
three this is a good one your clothes
are looser around your midsection this
is a really good indication that you're
in ketosis and it's working because
the first thing that's going to happen
is your liver is going to start dumping
fat and when you start getting rid of
the fatty liver you also start losing
weight around your organs and that's
called visceral fat and that's in your
midsection so as your midsection shrinks
it's a really good indication that it is
working which is way more important than
losing weight because of this what
you're fixing when you're doing the
ketogenic diet is insulin resistance and
the insulin receptor is becoming more
receptive and it's working in one of the
functions of insulin is to help you
absorb nutrients especially amino acids
so you're healing the body with more
proteins especially if you're menopausal
you have atrophy that's a good thing so
you're getting more protein and that's a
bit heavier per weight if you compare
that to actual fat per weight so it's
all about getting healthy to lose weight
not lose weight to get healthy and part
of getting healthy is to be able to
absorb these nutrients and allow these
proteins to get in your body when a lot
of people start out they have insulin
resistance and they're usually deficient
in amino acids because they can't pull
it in so they have a hard time absorbing
protein all right that was number three
number four
energy increase why because ketones come
from fat dietary fat and your body fat
and if we take a look at the two fuel
sources we have fat in glucose we look
at the calories in fat per gram compared
to the calories in carbs per gram fat is
nine carbs are four that's less than
half of the calories so there's more
than twice as much energy in fat than
glucose and when you go into ketosis
you're tapping into all this store fat
your potential energy so you get to have
that back and use that to actually get
things done versus when you're not in
ketosis you're running on glucose and
you're dependent on the next meal that
you eat because you're eating so darn
frequently and the burning of fat and
ketones are much more efficient and
cleaner fuel number five is your
cognitive function increases that's
memory focus and attention that that's
because ketones fix your brain they fix
the nerve cell if you have damage in
your neurons from too much sugar okay
because that basically damages the
mechanism and it kind of starves out the
neurons and this is why diabetics have a
greater incidence of dementia and
problems with a cognitive function
because of the destruction in the brain
but when you're in ketosis these ketones
feed the brain cells directly they
bypass this damage and finally your
brain cells get fuel and your cognitive
function increases like when I am
fasting in the morning I'm really in the
hardcore ketosis and I do these videos I
have much less editing they just like I
can just go right through it very fast
versus if I eat and try to do a video
takes a lot more editing all right
number six ketones will help with
inflammation and pain why because
ketones are anti-inflammatory mole
molecules if you have any type of
inflammatory condition whether it's an
autoimmune problem or arthritis and you
go on the ketogenic diet you're going to
feel a lot less inflammation and that's
a really good clue to tell if you're in
ketosis or not all right number seven
when you eat food you are going to feel
more satisfied okay and this relates to
another thing I talked about when you
have insulin resistance you can't absorb
as much nutrition because insulin is not
working to help transport those
nutrients into the cell
so when the cell becomes more sensitive
to insulin you are now going to absorb
more nutrients and you're going to feel
more satisfied when you eat whereas
before you're eating eating eating and
it's everything is just not filling you
up and or satisfying you now it could be
the type of food that you're eating is
is not nutrient dense but there's also
the factor of your body absorbing the
nutrients all right number eight better
mood if you were depressed before if you
had anxiety you're going to find that
you're just happier you're just going to
feel better it's going to uplift your
mood why because there's this thing
called brain insulin resistance okay and
you're fixing insulin resistance in the
brain and the Brain the neurons are
getting more fuel and that greatly helps
the neurotransmitters it helps your
hormones it helps your mood I mean there
are 15 studies okay that I looked at
that all associate your mood changing
when you're on the ketogenic diet but
the results are kind of mixed but I'll
tell you why there mixed okay because
some of the studies are on mice and
how do you really know if that mice had
a shift in mood I mean it's it's kind of
difficult you can't really compare a
mouse that's in depression with a human
that's in depression I think that's a
real difficult one so just because
something is high fat doesn't mean it's
ketogenic diet and in some of these
studies they're using it just a high fat
diet but the carbs are really high like
30 of the calories are carbs when it
should be like five percent of the
calories other studies they just use
ketones they don't actually put the
person on the ketogenic diet and then
they say oh yeah see ketogenic diet
doesn't work for for uplifting your mood
because we use ketones well taking
ketones is different than doing the
ketogenic diet all right number nine and
this is the best indicator to know that
you're in ketosis out of all of these
and that is
no appetite you lose your appetite okay
you can go for a longer period of time
without being hungry why because your
body is finally eating fat when you're
not eating because when you're going
between meals you're no longer are
dependent on the carbs your body can
actually eat the fat on your actual body
which is a New Concept for a lot of
people that are dieting and not having
an appetite makes it really easy to
stick to long term all right so now that
you have that information the next best
thing to know is what is the best
version of a ketogenic diet to start and
how do you do it and for that I put up
this video right here